[Music]
we're actually going to be looking back
in revelation chapter 14 on the verse
right before verse 4 which i'll read
these are they which were not the filed
with woman for they are virgins these
are they which follow the lamb
whithersoever he goeth these were
redeemed from among men being the first
fruits unto god and to the land
the second question right here is first
what is meant by the hundred and forty
four thousand
not the filed with woman mean
virgins
not defiled with women simply means
there is no illicit union no illicit
association between error and truth if
you read revelation 17 verse 2 with whom
the kings of the earth have committed
fornication revelation 18 verse 3 says
something very similar
fornication spiritually means illicit
union between truth and error which
amounts to the entire thing being
corrupt and so
the 144 000 have kept themselves
theologically pure doctrinally pure in
others they have been faithful to thus
sent the lord jesus said man shall not
live by bread alone but by every word
and elohim explains clearly every word
he meant every commandment which is the
standard of righteousness and if you
study uh christ's responses to the
temptations all three they all come from
a section of deuteronomy that deal with
the that deals with the 10th commandment
you're only 5 through 11. christ's
responses come from deuteronomy 6 and
deuteronomy 8 the section that deals
with the 10 commandments and so you can
understand the correctness of loy
statement when he said man shall not
live by bread alone but by every word he
was referring to the every word being
the ten commandments and frequently in
the bible you'll see commandments and
word used next to each other as parallel
statements because frequently
commandment is word and word is
commandment and so the um the the 144
thousand they have not involved
themselves with a system that is based
on violating the law of god because the
law of god is the standard of
righteousness every doctrine every
theory every profession must be tested
by the law of god they are faithful to
god's law which is another way of saying
their faithfulness is christ and his
righteousness
so they're not defined
with women mean false churches
because we see the women in revelation
uh 17 verse 5 and upon her head was a
crown was a name written mystery babylon
the great the mother of harlots and
abominations of the earth so there's
babylon and all the harlots the
daughters they're the same same genetic
strain they have different names but
same thing they're opposed to the law of
god
let me just digress briefly hopefully
helpfully
the law of god is really the test of
truth
a man will go and risk his life on the
the war zone to provide medical care he
will do whatever or she asks that person
obey god's law the person will say no
no
or yes but only nine the law of god is
absolutely the test of correct doctrine
that's why it's the law unto the
testimony if they speak not according to
this word it is because there is no
light and so 144 000 are faithful to
god's truth
and all his commandments are truths
they are not mingled with error that is
what fornication they means or mingle
with women their virgins they've lived a
doctorally pure life they have followed
thus the lord and nothing else
amen and just as god he separated the
light from the darkness
also have to be separated from this
communion with with you know how
community has light with darkness and
righteousness and unrighteousness that
doesn't work they've got to be separated
very good thanks for that so now the
final question is revelation 14 verse 4
calls the 144 000 the first fruits unto
god into the land
what is it by the first truth
the first verse was the second ceremony
of the seven feasts the israelites had
to celebrate uh beginning with um
the feast of pentecost not pentecost
um
uh
we symbolize the death of christ the
word is left the passover that was the
first one the last one was the feast of
tabernacles right after the day after
passover the feast of 11 bread began
and
feast the first fruit began the third
day after passover which is the third
day after the resurrect the crucifixion
of christ it was the waving of the very
first uh part of the harvest if you
planted barley or wheat whatever the
first of that to ripen was reaped and
taken to the priest and the priest
waited to god for god to accept it
meaning that the larger harvest will
also be acceptable to him that's why
christ and those who end up with him are
the first fruits of the larger
resurrection to come and so the 144 000
are called the first fruits because
they're special to god they are ahead of
the larger you know 144 thousand would
be closer to god than anybody else they
would have gone through trials and
tribulations that no one else will go
through because they'll be living in a
time when there'll be trouble such as
the world has never seen and so they
have that first fruit status
which is that which precedes the general
harvest
and um they'll be alive when jesus
christ comes so in that sense they see
him
ahead of the righteous dead who will
come up
amen christ is the first fruits christ
personifies the first fruits first
corinthians 15 20 21 22 144 000 along
with christ even as christ took some
people with him when many rows 144 000
at the end of time is sort of a larger
fulfillment of that group
amen and also first fruits
for those that also as elusive was
mentioning about the feast and passover
and you know feast of tabernacles that's
in leviticus chapter 23 for all those
that's right
thank you
all seven feasts are in that chapter all
seven yes
praise god by the way the first fruits
also symbolize the resurrection of
christ because the first fruit the first
verse were waived the third day after
pentecost you had not tentacled he kept
saying pentecost passover you had
passover on the 14th day you have feast
of 11 bread begins the next day the 15th
and then that it was considered the holy
sabbath a ceremonial sabbath and the day
after that
was the waving of the first fruits and
so it symbolizes the resurrection of
christ on the third day the first suits
were waved on the third day
that's why paul says christ rose the
third day according to the scriptures in
first corinthians 58 and that's where we
go to answer that question according to
the scriptures where is that the bible
teaches that christ will rise the third
day but you've got to study to uncover
that bible truth
and the key elements are leviticus 23.
amen
thank you for that elder squid
you